[Music]
six o'clock friday morning we do begin
with that breaking news an arrest in the
deadly shooting at the mirage the
incident caused chaos inside that
property as you can imagine in fact it
was closed for hours while metro police
investigated our mary jane bellies
joining us live on the strip with some
details on the arrest and mary jane
victims still recovering this morning
john and heather that's absolutely right
metro police say they have located and
arrested the suspect all within six
hours when the shooting first started
according to metro police a fight broke
out in a hotel room between four people
who knew each other one person in the
room shot the three others and that
shooter then left the room one person
has died the injured shooting victims
were taken to umc hospital and were
listed in critical condition as of this
morning the mirage hotel remained on
lockdown during this incident
to see if we're getting ready to go in
there and i'm glad you let us know that
was in a room it wasn't
especially with the way things are going
nowadays
frightening that it happened to someone
that's just the bottom line it happened
with someone
now take a look at this video here is
what it looked like inside the mirage
hotel and casino while it was unfolding
and some hotel guests reported there
were some confusion there but the mirage
is now back open and guests were allowed
to come back to their room after is
blocked off because of the shooting and
investigators say this is an isolated
incident and there is no threat to the
public at this time reporting live mary
jane belliesa live local now